a 3d printer in action
it's just received the command to print
a piece of jewelry in about three hours
time it will become part of the
collection of items designed by German
artist Silvia Weiden Bock her creations
are a result of what she sees in her
surroundings
sometimes concrete like coral or
abstract like a kaleidoscope vine box
studied gold and silver smithing in
southern Germany up until a few years
ago she only used traditional methods to
create certain objects I'm the Fonz
glasses
I started out with a very classical
silversmith training right from the
start I learned to work with traditional
tools and take the ideas that I had and
put them onto paper first and then
develop them with original material
material on this in cans glass effect so
you define a setting like these here are
traditional tools a file and so on
that's a miner and now it's exciting for
me to add another tool to my toolbox
such as the haptic arm which gives me
even more freedom because of a lot of
high height knocking this is the haptic
arm she's talking about it's a digital
tool used to manipulate virtual objects
on the computer it's similar to a clay
sculpting tool it can be torn muscle
that is opa classmates I can famille
this mash or object that you see here
that's Perseid and can matter yeah
that's oof I can add material or cut it
out understand is we just invited us
material I can determine is it a soft
material or easy to press through with
these various tools cooking Mitchell
this way is really an interesting way to
work in Co Sanders in tesander handy in
slices
vine BOC is currently
artist-in-residence at the Victoria and
Albert Museum in London in November one
of her 3d creations a jewelry box will
be displayed among the Gilbert
collection of decorative arts Silvia for
us was an obvious choice because she
reacts so sensitively to historic
material but she's not historicist she
takes inspiration from the objects and
then creates new and incredibly exciting
work for me it's disheartening isn't
inspir for me these pieces are a huge
inspiration for their detailed precision
that the way the artist treated the
materials and for their technical
innovations in a web cieaura at the time
these were created porcelain would have
been something totally new and that's
where I see lots of parallels with what
I'm doing
in the meantime a growing number of
fashion labels such as Alexander McQueen
a ofon DeForest and Icarus are using 3d
printers for accessories shoes are also
slowly making a footprint Dutch designer
eros fun happen incorporated 3d boots
into a collection created with architect
REM koolhaas back in her studio Weinberg
prepares to print another piece of
course all of this technology depends on
updated software and a good internet
connection any lapses in either will
result in a breakdown of the process
after three hours the prototype for a
bracelet is finally finished
you stinker I think the hype around 3d
printing is over the technology has been
around for more than 30 years and
artists have been using it for about 10
years
Dean Yan what's exciting now is how
material will be used how it will be
refined or combined with other materials
I'm also very interested in metal
printing and applying it more
exclusively often cause our exclusive
mutate to try with her 3d jewelry silvia
Weiden bak manages to represent today's
site-geist
[Music]